okay today I'm going to talk to you
about limiting reactants we're going to
see how to work out the mass of a
product based upon information about the
mass of a reactant in a chemical
reaction a reaction stops when all of
the reactants are used up so therefore
the mass of the product is limited by
the amount of reactant that we start off
with now to work this out we need to
know this equation triangle here N
equals M over m our M stands for the
mass whenever we're doing these types of
calculations the mass is given in grams
n is the number of moles so kind of the
number of particles involved in the
reaction and M R means relative formula
mass now this could also be relative
atomic mass it just depends on whether
we're talking about an element or a
compound so let's have a look at this
question we've got to calculate the
amount of aluminium oxide which is being
formed so the first thing that we need
to do is we need to write a simple
equation balance symbol equation for
this reaction so we've got aluminium is
burned in air so we have aluminium if we
have burning happening
it must be reacting with oxygen in order
to form aluminium oxide okay in order to
deduce ionic formula you can watch
another video and also to balance
equations you can watch another video as
well but I'm just going to write this
nice and quickly just in front of here
so what I've got is a balance symbol
equation so what I'm trying to figure
out is the mass of this which is being
produced if I start off with a limiting
reactant which is 135 grams of this
that's going to limit the amount of this
I can make so the first thing I need to
do is I need to find the relative
formula mass of these different these
different things here okay so if I just
get my periodic table I can find out the
relative atomic mass of aluminium is 27
please note at the moment I'm just going
to ignore the numbers in front you'll
see why in a minute
and for aluminium oxide I've got two
aluminium atoms and three oxygen atoms
so I'm going to have 2 times 27 plus
that's the mass of oxygen and I've got
three of them so it's going to be 3
times 16 so I'm just going to use my
calculator to find out what that is
so 2 times 27 plus 3 times 16
the answer is 102 so the relative
formula mass of that one is a hundred
and two now at the moment I can't find
the mass of this because I need to find
the mass of this I need information
about the relative formula mass and the
number of moles however I do know the
mass of this because it says I've got
135 grams of aluminium so that's my mass
of aluminium right there so to find the
number of moles of aluminium what I need
to do is I need to do so if I'm finding
a Mont number of moles I need to do the
mass divided by the relative formula
mass so I'm going to do the mass so
sorry to find a number of moles I need
to do the mass which is 135 divided by
the relative formula mass which is 27 so
the number of moles is just going to be
that on the calculator 135 divided by 27
which is 5 so I've got five moles of
this reacting now the next bits really
clever what I need to do is I need to
look at something called the molar ratio
now this is the point where I look at
the numbers in front of the different
different substances I have a 4 in front
of here and a 2 in front of here now
what that means is for every 4 aluminium
atoms I'm forming two molecules of
aluminium oxide so to express that as a
ratio I could show that it's a 4 to 2
ratio
because four to two now an easier more
simplified way of showing that is it's a
two to one ratio now what we need to do
next is this if it's a for a two to one
ratio that means for every two atoms of
this we make one molecule of that so if
we have five molecules of this we need
to find out half of that cuz it's a two
to one ratio so very five of this we
find so 5 divided by 2 which is 2 point
5 moles so for every 5 moles of
aluminium reacting we produce 2.5 moles
of aluminium oxide so we can now go
ahead now we have information about the
number of moles and we have information
about the relative formula mass we can
now find our mass so to find the mass of
this all that we need to do is cover up
the N and we're left with the number of
moles times the relative formula mass so
my number of moles here is 2.5 and the
relative formula mass of this is a
hundred and two so therefore my
calculation is just going to be that
there so the mass of this that's quickly
he's my calculator again is 2.5 x a
hundred and two so the answer is 255
grams so what I've done there is I've
found based on this was my limiting
reactant here because I had a finite
amount of it it reacted with oxygen the
air so for every 135 grams of aluminium
that reacts I'm going to produce 255
grams of aluminium oxide thank you